aloha everybody welcome back local shop
wicked donuts are celebrating their one
year anniversary this month with
a special hawaiian theme chef teddy is
back with this time in studio
not via skype um just show us how the
ninth island itself which is las vegas
if you didn't know that can join in on
the wicked luau
hey chef teddy hello oh what you doing
hola aloha you know all cultures here on
las vegas now
all right so first and foremost i gotta
get
laid right you got to get laid and i
brought one for you
there you go all right
in hawaii everybody okay let's talk
about the why you choose the hawaiian
theme for your first anniversary because
that's so special
yes well and we'll decorate while you do
that yes hawaii i love it
it's wonderful it's a personal thing for
me
my mom was a hawaiian dancer years ago
toured around the country i learned who
hula
i know i love that and so uh i wanted to
bring that to our first anniversary
it's fun it's wild beautiful flavors
it's great so i have the pineapple icing
uh icing this is very unique for a donut
yes
hawaiian themed donuts so tell us about
what are what are the toppings what are
the flavors that we're getting into
this is a mai tai and so a
pineapple grenadine and orange i want
you to take your orange
drizzle okay oh i wow i'm sorry you're
moving i have the yellow
so drizzle it just like this
okay on the donut right no on the on the
icing just like that
okay come on rocky sorry okay guys i'm
leaving
this squeeze the book this is hard work
okay i'm gonna
crave you look at that guys there we go
there's the orange and now the
grenadine okay and i have the orange do
hawaiian theme without color and
pineapple
that's right it's colorful now take your
donut just drop it in oh
and press down a little bit drag it
forward
toward you and there you go look at that
look at that
look at that wow these are beautiful
okay obviously yours is
far better than mine but this is just
one of the things you can get all month
tell us about the other items you're
doing this month in the specials
pineapple uh we are doing
the pina colada which is delicious
this is the fruit orange and guava
we have the lime mango which is
lime huey and mango oh my gosh
pineapple preter and they're just gonna
have to come visit you to get a taste
okay and obviously
they also have very vegas like alcohol
infused donuts too so everybody check
out wicca donuts this month
happy one year awesome to you jc thank
you thank you